did you know that LeBron James had not
won but two NFL tryout offers during the
2011 NBA lockout LeBron received actual
offers from the Dallas Cowboys and the
Seattle Seahawks but get this he said
he's seriously considered trying out and
would have made the team too both
Cowboys owner Jerry Jones and Seahawks
head coach Pete Carroll invited him for
a workout and Pete even sent him a
custom Jersey but wait there's more
people LeBron's in a circle tried to
talk him into accepting the tryout you
can do that when you were considered the
number one high school football Prospect
in Ohio but the transition to basketball
and football may not have been as tough
as you think look at it like this with a
frame at 6 9 250 LeBron could have
changed the way we view receivers in the
NFL he's a pure athlete and some even
called him a bigger version of Randy
Moss but in the end LeBron chose
basketball but it still would have been
interesting to see how his NFL career
could have turned out if he decided to
switch Sports